there is a colonial woman on the wing
country
in traditional colonial girls
it's possible for people to grab hold of
the intercom but we have special codes
to be able to get our voice across hi
i'm christine fernandez i was an
international flight attendant for
premium airline for about seven years i
was based in dubai and have experience
working in first class and as a senior
leading the cabin crew today i'll be
looking at flight attendant scenes from
movies and judging how real they are
come aboard mr young is you here's the
way to your private suite
and some champagne
i love this one
i felt like that was the airline that i
worked for so
like at the bar that they walk into you
know that's almost exactly what it
looked like so that for us would be the
business class bar first class is insane
you have like your own private suite
where the doors close automatically
and the best part is the shower yes
there is a shower spa in order to use
that you have allocated time so it's 30
minutes and the flight attendants would
go ahead and set up the spa for you so
that all the towels are warm the floors
are heated the floors are heated in your
shower spa
on the plane so it's pretty wild and
it's like a refreshment drink afterwards
it's very beautiful
nick
we can't afford this
these pajamas are fancier than any of my
real clothes
so we hand out pajamas you have the
slippers so you have a small amenities
kit which is like this size every
toothbrush you have your socks and eye
shades i think 10 out of 10. honestly
when i was watching that bath scene i
felt like i was back out i was like oh i
know there's people oh that book's messy
what's wrong with messi
the first thing about that clip that
stood out to me you wouldn't believe was
actually the hair
because the uniform standards of flight
attendants is so very specific or
especially for the airline that i worked
with so all hair must be
back right so if it's shoulder length
hair
and it's not touching the shoulders you
can have it down but anything longer
than that then you have to have up
definitely away from the face with a
maximum of six
bobby pins the reason why hair was up
was more from a hygiene perspective
because you're in food service in the
event of an emergency having your hair
up is good so when the hair was out here
i was like
not too much
[Music]
the way that most flight attendants see
the lavatory is like it's a public
toilet
in dry air so it's like the least
sexiest place
then anything can really go down
getting steamy in the public toilet in
the air is like very undesirable
for most for most but not ruling it out
for everyone will you have dinner with
me
okay that was like a super cute moment
but we're really not supposed to do that
so okay well bangkok can be really
magical
first of all
having a cute passenger on board that
you're just like
quite rare but also to have that like
open flirtation in the middle of the
aisles probably someone on the side
being like excuse me can i have a drink
or excuse me here's some rubbish
so that flirtation if it were to really
happen it would happen more in the
galley because it's more quiet and you
can just sort of like chat with each
other but definitely
flirtation can happen on the plane i
used to get asked if um if i would like
to marry someone someone once asked me
they were like um give me your number
please and i was like
i don't think that's appropriate would
you like a drink instead and then they
were like i promise i will call you
and i'm like that's exactly why i'm not
giving you my number maybe like a six
out of ten there were a lot of things
happening in one
scene which may happen
in different scenarios miss
you cannot be up here hello grandpa
i'm sorry i just want to be here with my
friends
oh how often do we have to drink with
drunk passengers
all the time pretty much every flight
one of the cabins that we had had a
whole bar in it there would be people
who would do the whole entire flight 13
to 14 hours just at the bar we've had
dancing we've had people go from like
being the quietest passengers at the
beginning of the flight to like by the
end of the hours of drinking is like
everyone's best friend inviting everyone
to the holiday that they're about to go
to passengers are not allowed up here in
first class it's a policy i'm sorry
that's very true
that's how strict it is like that's how
real it is
miss
um
no
it's not me yes
in the night flights like we walk
through the different cabins just to
check how everything is there were like
a lot of seats and these guys pretty
much made their way into there and then
covered themselves in blankets and had
and like basically did their whole
flight as business class it's not
allowed but it can happen
whatever you say stove
it's steve
touching is definitely
not allowed
uh does it happen
sometimes but we're really firm we're
very stern because that's definitely
crossing the line so it's a direct
confrontation of that's not acceptable
and if it continues it's never continued
so i've never gone to that level i have
an announcement too there is a colonial
woman on the wing
it's possible for people to grab hold of
the intercom it's knowing what buttons
to press 10 out of 10 plus more i can
imagine it happening in real life
never would that happen
but i did once get sent a photo of a
snake being on a plane yet i don't know
where it came from but someone said this
was on my flight and there was just a
little little friendly little snake but
never i'm not at this level
one thing that you can expect on a
flight in first class is a falcon
with something that even we're trained
for on the airline that i worked with
odd things happen on the plane my
flatmate she delivered a baby on board
on our flight on all cabins uh everyone
gets handed out like a hot towel to like
freshen up and one time i handed out
this towel the guy just except like he
took it and he like just looked at me
and then he was like
and i was like yeah like you know he's
and he's like
like he ate the hot towel
i couldn't believe it
[Music]
what's up with the oxygen mask deploying
no sorry about that
you're not going to believe what came
out of the instrument panel
definitely if there's anything to be
concerned about you can just go straight
to the cockpit like anything emergency
one
just ring or go in most of the time if
there's heavy turbulence the flight
attendant wouldn't be in the cockpit the
captain will say for all crews to take
their seats so even at that level no
crew will be walking around
so definitely like
like a 0.5 out of 10. sir you're gonna
have to check i got it no i'm sorry that
bag won't fit no no i'm not hey i'm not
checking my bag okay okay there's no
need to raise your voice sir i'm not
raising my voice this would be raising
my voice to you this is
one thousand percent true it happens all
the time i feel like i've had this exact
conversation with someone but i will say
the the flight attendant's composure
here is also very real that's what's
expected of you
one time
i was still new you can't really land
until everyone's seated but one guy
really wanted to go to the toilet
and he kept on looking at me like can i
go and i was like i don't know if i'm
going he goes now i'm going he brought
like
he brought a plastic bag with him and he
turned around and i didn't understand
what he was doing
and then as it turns out he urinated in
the bag and then he tied it up and then
he put it in front of me
and like what do you do did that just
happen in my real life you know what
just give me a little
okay it's not like i have a bomb in here
it's not like i want to blow up the
plane i just want to stow my bag
according to your safety regulation even
if what you're saying is a joke or
even if it's like completely
hypothetical like he was just angry but
that's something that would cause a
flight to be
definitely delayed so if someone says
that
everyone would definitely be
um deplaned so there are some serious
repercussions around that you need a
nine out of ten
i hear about it all the time i just
never experienced it sometimes it might
be in business class because the suites
can be shared one time the guys in first
class rang all of the stations just to
let us know that
there was a couple having sex in the
in the shower spa
the thing that stands out to me is
that's how small the toilet is
that's the kind of space that you would
be working with that's the possible
things that could happen where your foot
could actually end up in the toilet bowl
return to your seat now please
they can knock knock knock but there's
you know there's so much you can do but
i don't believe any specific protocol
around that it would be like this is not
safe because if turbulence happens we
can't two people can't be in the toilet
let alone fasten seat belts whilst you
know so that's probably the angle that
it would come from
it's like you can't just assume and jump
to the gun and be like guys no sex
allowed
you just kind of leave it nine
[Applause]
so the fake planes for us we call them
like the simulators the overall setup of
it is pretty accurate the tone here was
more like you know they're sitting there
waiting for it to happen when you're in
training college it's a bit more serious
all of the tests especially the safety
and security one they're known to be the
most stressful
times there are so many things that
you've got to remember beyond just the
commands you've got to memorize things
like how many
doors are there where are the fire
extinguishers located and you've got
different aircrafts to
memorize so if you're working on this
aircraft then you must know where all of
the safety and security equipment is for
that particular aircraft it's really
treated like a serious exam period
[Music]
when they do the training around safety
it's like that you're in the situation
of
acting out like an evacuation so you
actually you have to like you have to
raise your voice you actually have to
act with that urgency we are to be able
to
evacuate a plane with all different
quantities of passengers but 420
is for the larger aircrafts we have to
be able to evacuate that quantity of
passengers in 90 seconds people think
that flight attendants the front that
you have is very friendly and
approachable and therefore
not really that serious but it's quite a
serious role so much of it is really
about your role in safety and that's
never ever talked about like
health emergencies they happen on the
plane well we would describe sometimes
the job kind of like being like swans
swimming swans up the top it's like very
nice and smooth and calm and underneath
you've got like the little feet overall
i'd say pretty accurate like eight out
of ten
[Music]
i've never had anyone
sing on a flight in terms of performing
on the airline and
no and then especially
romance like public open romance the
whole performance thing
is definitely not something that i've
experienced in real life
the truest thing about this clip is
probably just the bar cut
and someone trying to get through and
not being able to so what flight
attendants do sometimes you've let
someone go through the toilet but you're
halfway through a big row of seats
so
sometimes you'll just let them wait
just let them wait and and they know
that they will wait and that's okay not
really that realistic i'd say probably a
one
there's even a story that went around
that someone put their baby in the hat
rack because they weren't too sure where
to put the baby i hope you enjoyed this
video if you did go ahead and click the
button to watch some more